hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about hummus and after I'm done
with this video chances are you're going
to probably drive out and get some
hummus to start consuming it because
it's quite an amazing combination of six
ingredients chickpea tahini olive oil
lemon garlic and sea salt now when you
buy hummus read the ingredients and make
sure it does not consume anything else
like preservatives and chemicals and soy
oil okay don't get that one give get it
basically just with these ingredients
now let's just first talk about the
chickpea garbanzo bean it actually has
properties to improve insulin resistance
it helps your blood sugar so even though
there's a good amount of carbohydrate it
will not affect your blood Sugar's too
much at all I have diabetics that
consume this and it doesn't really
affect them so that's the good news
plus if we add these tahini and olive
oil
that fat buffers any type of you know
spike in insulin okay now I'm sure
there's a point where you can consume
too much but here's the key is when you
consume hummus make sure you use
vegetables not pita dip I'm sorry okay
so it also has 75% in soluble fibers
when this fiber goes into the large
colon these microbes start consuming it
and they make this thing called butyric
acid which then feeds the colon cells
this acid is also really good for
insulin resistance so it's going to help
you in two ways now chickpeas are also
high in which also helps the
liver detoxify certain things like heavy
metals and also byproducts or toxins
from Candida so that's pretty cool and
then we get to tahini button that sesame
seed oil sesame seed oil has a lot of
properties that sisal vitamins but it's
high in a methionine which is an amino
acid which is good for depression and an
anti gray hair factor so if you're
deficient in this amino acid you can get
gray hair and I'm not saying it's going
to help your hair but it could affect it
gallbladder support omega-3
acids and a lot of other nutrition it's
kind of similar to peanut butter but
it's more bland olive oil I've done a
seminar on that restore the video that
recently anti-inflammatory supports the
cardiovascular systems high in vitamin E
okay I get the extra virgin
lemon lemon is really good for
preventing kidney stones it's also high
in vitamin C and has a lot of other
things as well garlic it's probably the
most powerful anti microbial things you
can consume and anti-cancer and there's
a lot of phytonutrients I mean it's good
for parasites and fungus and you name it
and then we got the sea salt sea salt is
composed of 94 minerals so can I mean
this is an incredible combination of
ingredients to make hummus so it's okay
to consume it even on a ketogenic diet
so okay guys in summary you can either
find some from the health of store or
make it your own and put a recipe down
below check it out